scp 682 vs scp-023  could black shock the demon dog whose  glowing eyes portend death be the way to  usher the hard to destroy reptile into  the great beyond when 682 was made to  gaze into zero two three's eyes the  foundation knew it would either kill  scp-682  or a member of its immediate family and  predictably  scp-682 seemed to suffer no ill effects  meaning a family member would have to go  nobody expected that family member to be  the star epsilon serpentis which  underwent a premature supernova a year  after the 682-023 cross test after which  682 became silent for a few days perhaps  mourning a lost loved one after this  cross test between 682 and nescp's that  affect the family members of their  victims have been strictly prohibited